my takeaway from this is a little bit  different than I think everyone else is  I'm shocked there was any pushback at  all internally from Twitter because you  can see there are some Jack Dorsey  didn't even know right he didn't even  know and their employees pushing back I  I think it just goes to it goes to show  something I've talked about for a long  time  they're great at finding where The  Gatekeepers are and taking those spots  it's not that they have to take  everything they just find who holds the  keys go grab the keys this was that one  the same lady who suspended Trump she  was the one who did all this all you  need is one good spot yeah yeah